so we've got to move away from the exit
fee but brexit has dominated the news
for as long as anyone can remember but
isn't it time we stopped talking
meaningful votes and started having
meaningful conversations about the real
national crisis this year there have
been 100 killings including 41 stabbings
in the UK public concern has grown so
deep that it's wiped out the
Conservatives reputation as the party of
law and order only one in four people
now think the Tories are the best for
dealing with crime that's the lowest in
14 years from the rights commentators of
criticised to resumes decision to reform
stop and search from the left pundits
focus on austerity and historically no
police Dundas this game of political
ping-pong has been on display most
visibly between London's mayor and the
Home Secretary in truth there is no one
quick fix to the problem
intelligence-led police searches more
bobbies on the beat for community
policing absentee father's the role of
school expulsion and reimagining our
failing war on drugs must all be
considered as perhaps in Glasgow the
public deserves a comprehensive approach
the only ones getting off scot-free when
politicians play the blame game are the
criminals
this is a catastrophic situation Majid
and I think the only silver lining is
that it is being taken seriously by the
political establishment
I personally vinery it hasn't taken this
number of young people dying before we
have it being described as a national
emergency but we have the Prime Minister
speaking about it we have a task what's
being a simple we've now had the
Chancellor announce an extra hundred
million pounds for the police even
though the government still doesn't
admit but on the funding of the police
and austerity has been part of the
problem in the first place which for me
is just logically nonsensical now but I
think I still have a few issues with the
way this debate is being carried out I'm
very interested in the public health
approach that was adopted in Scotland
but I don't know how much people
understand it and for example the former
Deputy Mayor of London Mathew Ryder has
written about this the fact that a
public health approach actually requires
more stop and search more data
collection tougher enforcement a lot of
the people advocating it I think feel or
assume that it's kind of a hands-off
approach it's not and I think this goes
to the deeper issue for me there is a
lack of trust in the communities
affected by this and the authorities
truth the root causes of this in my
opinion are relatively obvious we have
left poor areas - the exposure of
organized crime
there's exploited vulnerable kids who
are not receiving an education that's
interested and we've always had problems
of violence young men disenfranchised
choice government barnable young men
poor young men young men who interested
in solving this problem in society in my
opinion we change what's different this
time a few factors are different social
media is a massive factor music that I'm
not familiar with I think is legal drill
drill music is a massive factor the idea
that you can live fast get a lot of
money and die young is a massive fact
they don't care that's it suddenly they
see someone on the street corners
driving a BMW with fantastic looking
girlfriends or boyfriends or whatever it
might be
and I think those were floods that
weren't that I think are new and bring
different situations in and the elephant
in the room in many instances is the
breakdown of family units and too many
absent dads and kids having kids that
was in my talk up but did you know did
you know did you know Nick that the
public when surveyed have just said that
they put concern for life crime now
their concern for NHS it's second only
second only to plan I agree and I will
yield and you're absolutely right to
find a hundred million pounds now as
extraordinary as they have do right cut
the money but then they released three
billion pounds for housing funding now
I'm not saying housing isn't important
of course we should be having housing
but you make three billion available so
you can build houses and a hundred
million available to stop kids stabbing
each other I don't know magic money tree
in a second we're going to hear from a
kid who saw another kid being stabbed
but just first I want to back up what
after said there is obviously as the
head of the met said herself Cressida
dick a correlation between the cut in
police numbers by 20,000 since 2010 and
the rise in knife crime and street crime
how could anybody given the fact that
bricks and water police stations are
closing we are not seeing policemen on
the street in the same way I mean
Michelle's are the the Diane of common
sense but honestly if I was Prime
Minister I would ban the sale of knives
to anyone under 18 like you can't buy
bleach anymore because of acid attacks I
wouldn't I would impose a knife amnesty
I would have bins on street so you could
put away your blade but anyway enough of
me because that's here from somebody
who's experienced this it was basically
over girl is over go and they wanted
didn't have a fight he just ended up
stabbing him it was a she I was right
there I just saw a group of young young
boys all crowd have nothing to say I
think we need to make an important point
as well because I think sometimes people
here in I've come and they just think
London so I've just got a quick
statistic to show you that actually he
says since 2010 you've seen a rise in
knife knife offenses in London by 11
percent but actually much broader than
that English and Welsh Welsh Council is
forty five point seven percent so that's
the first point I want to make that this
isn't just a inner city in a London
thing which is why doesn't help where a
lot of people are just blaming the
London Mayor no I would probably counter
that there and say that actually the the
increase is so small in London because
it was already so right in the first
place but
but small but what I would say is this
public health approach I was quite
auntie that originally because I think
it was in Glasgow or something yeah I
know but I was originally auntie or
slightly Anthea and the reason that I
felt slightly auntie originally was
because I felt like it was almost
absorbing people of personal
responsibility which I disagree with but
the more that I have come to learn and
understand this issue it is to your
point serve deeply complex certainly
you've got children in primary schools
primary schools with knives and knuckle
dusters going to school and often it's
for prevention it's not because they
want to fight it is because they feel a
need to protect so so if we look at
there's an interesting guy an anti knife
campaigner I just bring him in because
what I feel needs to happen is people
from the communities that are affected
by this need to be working much closer
with the government to look at fixing
how do we fix this because it's so
complicated is everything from lack of
youth centres and lack of engagement
with the use in terms of what they can
do through to family things and money
and let's look at an anti knife
campaigner I've took 30 laps away and
each one that I give out ten pound
batches but a large welcome to JD sports
I say you can have a twenty per voucher
by just by logic 10-pound vouchers this
is easy for me to split up you know I
mean and I was writing it I just write
in a voucher to question work from
Amnesty and the price of the voucher and
that's black keep winning keep changing
you need people that these kids can
relate to to be working with these kids
if you get a posh you know guy walking
in in his suit going hey kids to do
we're gonna get you to put down your
knifes they're gonna go I mean come on
they are and you need people that they
can relate to to inspire these kids to a
different way of life the complexity
point that you made if there's anyone
remember playing that coming up maybe
you younger than us SimCity the game was
so you'd have this computer game called
Sim City or when it was about allocating
allocating resources and the minute you
took the budget away from say the Armed
Forces in the game and put it towards
the police domestically you'd see a
foreign country about to invade you a
nun vice versa the minute you took this
money there and I think that's part of
the problem that we've got such a
complex problem that involves absentee
father's social media
police numbers of 20,000 you know all of
that has to be addressed so watch me so
let's find out what is the government
actually doing here's crime Minister
Victoria reckons we in the home office
are investing 220 million pounds on
intervention both in the short term but
also in the longer term because we know
these problems can arise they can take
time to arise but we need to intervene
as soon as we can to steer some of these
young people away from the path of
criminality which speaks to the point
you started with which is cash cash cash
therefore aleeah's cash but it's also I
think a cultural attitude towards what's
happening in our poor areas and if you
speak to young men like the one we just
saw on Sky News there they will tell you
that they live in violent areas where
people have to be violent just to
survive where you're not respected if
you don't learn to be but you've got
kids who don't want to be violent I want
to be armed having to be because of the
nature of the place that everyone they
feel left behind nobody has cared about
what's going on in those areas their
services have been taken away there is a
complete lack of trust between them and
the authorities because of this feeling
of neglect I just want to show you pizza
Chesney the father of Joey Chesney who's
one of the tragic victims of this
recently also outside of London just
listen to what he says about his
daughter because this is the this is
what's really going on and when you hear
these personal stories it really does
bring it home she was the nicest person
any of us know or know everything about
her was about being kind good and
thoughtful it's just there's no way I
found that so moving and so tragic but I
would also like to say that I wish all
of the children were victims of this
have been treated with the same dignity
and sympathy because I can't state
enough how malign some of them have been
in the media in a portrayed as if they
are criminals rather than child victims
which is actually what they are so I
hope that people will start to be more
compassionate so all of the victims of
this terrible situation